الرئيس بايدن عندما سافر إلى
إسرائيل بعد هجوم حماس في
7 أكتوبر وقتل ما يقرب من 100 إسرائيلي
الرئيس بايدن حذر إسرائيل من
ارتكاب نفس الأخطاء التي ارتكبتها أمريكا
بعد 911 ألا تسمح أه الغضب أه
يستهلكها ألا تسمح للغضب أن يقوده
ردهم أنت أكثر من أولئك منا الذين
يشاهدون العرض الآن وأكثر مني
أعرف مدى
استهداف الجيش الإسرائيلي لحماس بالفعل، وما
إذا كان الإسرائيليون يبذلون
كل ما في وسعهم لتجنب وقوع
إصابات في صفوف المدنيين، وما مدى سوء
عدد القتلى المدنيين بالفعل  على عكس
ما تدعي وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية التي تديرها حماس عن
مدى انتشار
الدمار فعليًا في غزة، هل تعتقد أن
الإسرائيليين أخذوا بنصيحة بايدن
بشأن عدم السماح للانتقام بأن يكون
مدفوعًا
بالغضب؟ ما يمكنني قوله عن هذا هو أنه
ليس تقييمًا  يمكن أن يتم
بناء على لقطة في
لحظة معينة هذا حوار مستمر
أه بين الولايات المتحدة وحكومة
إسرائيل وعندما تكون هناك
حوادث مثل تلك
التي ذكرتها للتو أه تثير المخاوف
أه توحي أه  ربما
لم يتم الاهتمام الكافي
أه بأرواح الفلسطينيين الأبرياء أه
التي تعلمون في نظرنا أنها
تساوي أرواح الأبرياء أه في أي مكان
يجب أن يذهب دون أن نقول نحن نطرح تلك
المخاوف مباشرة مع حكومة
إسرائيل وقد أثار الرئيس تلك
المخاوف مباشرة  أه مع رئيس
الوزراء لذلك بالنسبة لنا الأمر لا يتعلق
بتقييم فوري بقدر ما
يتعلق بعملية مستمرة لمحاولة توجيه
الأمور بأفضل ما يمكن أه الاتجاه
بما في ذلك أه لأي قتال
يبقى أه خلال مسار هذا
الصراع نحن  صدق أه حكومة
إسرائيل يمكن أن تستخلص الدروس أه
بناء على كيفية سير العمليات في الشمال
أه وتطبيق تلك الدروس
أه إلى حيثما يأخذ هذا
الصراع أه المضي قدما
عدد متزايد من الديمقراطيين في مجلسي النواب والشيوخ
يدفعون  لكي تضع الإدارة
شروطًا على المساعدات التي تستمر في
الذهاب إلى إسرائيل، يقول السيناتور بيرني ساندرز، على سبيل
المثال، إن أي مساعدات أمريكية يجب أن تكون
مشروطة بإنهاء إسرائيل لما
يسميه القصف العشوائي في غزة،
والالتزام بعدم إعادة احتلال غزة، وإعادة
الدخول في مفاوضات السلام من أجل
حل الدولتين المستقبلي، ما
رأيك في ذلك، ما رأيك في
الشروط المتعلقة
بالمساعدات المستقبلية، حسنًا، أعتقد أن ما أود قوله عن
جيك في هذه المرحلة هو أن
المساعدة التي تقدمها الولايات المتحدة
لأي بلد غير مشروطة،
فهي تأتي  مع اشتراط
استخدام المساعدات أه بما يتوافق مع
القانون الدولي بما يتوافق مع
قانون النزاع المسلح أه وأريد أن
أوضح أيضا أن الرئيس
قال أه أه إن لإسرائيل كل الحق
في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الهجمات المروعة التي حدثت  في 7 أكتوبر
أه هذا حق كل دولة هو
بالتأكيد حق إسرائيل ولسنا
فقط ندعم هذا الحق خطابيا
نحن كما قلت أه نقدم أه
مساعدة لإسرائيل حتى تتمكن من القيام
بذلك بأكثر طريقة ممكنة أه فعالية
أه  لكن إلى النقاط التي كنا
نتحدث عنها سابقًا في نفس هذا
الحديث أه تلك الحقوق تأتي مع
التزامات وهذا الالتزام يتضمن
أه إجراء هذا الصراع بطريقة
تميز أه المدنيين عن
غير المقاتلين بطريقة
تتناسب مع جميع  المتطلبات
المرتبطة بأه
القانون الدولي الإنساني ينطبق هنا
آخر شيء سأقوله في هذا الشأن مع أه
ومن المهم أن نضع في الاعتبار
أن إسرائيل تقاتل خصمًا
ليس فقط لا يلتزم بنفس
هذه المعايير بل يتباهى بها علنًا أه
والاستهزاء بها وعن
انتهاكاتها انتهاكات صارخة
للقانون الدولي أه لا
يقلل من التزامات إسرائيل ولكنه وجه
من وجوه هذا الصراع الذي يجعل
التحدي صعبا للغاية